Stephanie is a nine-year-old little girl
who for some reason has been abandoned
by her parents she lives in her house
all alone and just about takes care of
herself her only friend is a soft Turtle
toy whom she calls Francis a normal day
for Stephanie consists of watching
cartoons playing the piano preparing
smoothies for herself and spending time
with Francis the turtle one day when
Stephanie turns on the television the
news channels broadcast the miserable
situation of the world where some
Supernatural forces are wreaking havoc
in different countries they also
mentioned that a strict quarantine has
been declared and people are asked to
stay inside their homes however
Stephanie does not pay attention to such
matters and simply changes to her
cartoon channel being a nine-year-old
she is Clumsy at everything she does and
often makes a mess of the house however
she is still content and happy to live
alone without her parents the same day
as Stephanie is preparing a smoothie in
the kitchen she hears a sudden noise
coming from upstairs scared the little
girl rushes there only to find a ball
dropping as as if someone is inviting
her to play without knowing who the
person is Stephanie yells at him or her
and returns to the kitchen unfortunately
there she steps on a broken piece of
glass which causes her to scream in pain
but as there is no one to look after her
she quickly regroups and limps upstairs
where she grabs a first aid kit and
tends to her wound later at night
Stephanie prepares dinner and serves it
on plates for four people in the family
two for her parents and the other two
for her brother and herself none for
Francis that's just not right she then
brushes her teeth and sleeps after
reading a tale to her doll Francis the
next morning Stephanie places Francis on
the floor and urges him to play hide and
seek she then goes straight to a room
and hides inside a makeshift tent there
while she is looking at a family photo
album Stephanie Hears A Dangerous
creature's sound coming from outside the
house terrified she closes her mouth and
tries her best to remain quiet the
monster hurls near Stephanie but leaves
when it doesn't see anyone after a while
Stephanie slowly comes out of her tent
and approaches the wind window to take a
look at the creature sadly she sees no
one and it deduces that the creature has
escaped into the nearby Woods she then
tells Francis that the monster doesn't
like noises so they should remain silent
in the afternoon as Stephanie is playing
football with Francis she notices her
pet rabbit Mr Hopper wandering around
the garden turns out that he has somehow
managed to get out of his cage Stephanie
asks Mr Hopper to wait for a while and
rushes to the kitchen to prepare some
food for him after some time she comes
back with a bowl full of tomato sauce
she then tries to lure Mr Hopper back
inside but fails as the rabbit hops
towards the woods [ __ ] rabbit don't
deserve my tomato sauce anyway afterward
when Stephanie is brushing her teeth at
night the electricity suddenly cuts off
making her scared she then rushes to her
brother Paul's room and holds his hand
strangely the hand looks pale and weak
as if he is already dead but when
Stephanie urges Paul to protect her his
hand slowly moves implying that a
supernatural force is controlling him
now at night she hears a loud bang by
the window which scares the light life
out of her slowly and warily she goes to
Jack and finds blood all over the place
the little girl follows the trail and
finds her pet rabbit Mr Hopper badly
injured and bleeding on the table
enraged she enters Paul's room and
blames him for the rabbit's death and
the departure of their parents she then
picks up a baseball bat and starts
bashing his body which is lying on the
bed because of this the cloth covering
Paul's head slips which Reveals His
decomposed face the following night it
is raining and the power again cuts off
Stephanie goes to the basement to get
some candles and while there she notices
the washing machine shaking violently
like someone is trapped inside afraid
she runs straight to her makeshift tent
and sleeps late at night Stephanie hears
someone opening the door she walks
downstairs to check it and sees water
everywhere on the floor she assumes that
someone has managed to sneak inside the
house when lightning occurs one can
clearly see that someone is standing
behind her back I don't think I've ever
described a jump scare like that before
frightened Stephanie goes to the
bathroom and locks herself in inside the
footsteps start approaching her making
her close her mouth in horror but to her
surprise it's her parents Eric and Jane
who have returned to visit her after all
this the little girl reunites with her
parents and sleeps with them the next
day Jane changes her dress in front of
Stephanie assuming that she is sleeping
however she is wrong the little girl is
awake and she stares at her mother from
behind strangely there are some dot-like
scars on her mother's belly which
frightens Stephanie later she notices
her father carrying wooden blocks trying
to prepare a fence around the house he
claims that he is doing this to protect
the house from the monster seeing this
Stephanie rushes to her brother's room
but does not find his corpse there
without notifying anyone she then Walks
Into the Woods in search of her brother
but to her dismay she finds that her
parents have already buried Paul near
the backyard angry the little girl
frantically tries to dig out the body
with her hands but at the same time she
is called by her parents when Stephanie
returns home her mother Jane urges her
to never step out of the fence without
their permission the little girl obliges
but addresses her desire to have Paul
back in the house the next morning while
having pancakes for breakfast Stephanie
asks her mom why she left her alone in
the house Jane replies that it was not
her choice because they had assumed that
Stephanie was also captured by the
monster hearing this the little girl
tells her mother that the monster lives
in the woods and will attack them
whenever there is chaos or noise inside
the house she also mentions that one
should remain silent and calm when the
monster enters the house later at night
the dead body of Paul is brought back to
the house through the window by an
unseen Force both the parents are sad to
see this as they had just buried him
with heavy hearts however Stephanie
reacts normally as if nothing had
happened during dinner she asks Eric if
the monster brought her brother back and
Eric confirms it he also tells Stephanie
that the monster is after her and will
follow them wherever they go in the next
scene Stephanie secretly enters her
mother's room and finds numerous
newspaper articles posted on a board
including little children like her
committing heinous crimes she goes
through a book kept on the table and
gets to know that Jane is actually
trying to study brain surgery and its
procedures while she is looking through
other posters Jane rushes into the room
causing Stephanie to hide under the
table Jane looks worried and when she
looks at the brain pictures she loses
her temper and throws them away
afterwards Stephanie can be seen
chilling in the bathtub when Eric
approaches her he tells her that the
monster is not an external Force but
only the result of her bad feelings
hence she needs to control herself and
try not to let the negative feelings
take over her Stephanie politely agrees
but in return asks her father why she
was left alone this makes Eric emotional
and he slowly Whispers that he was
afraid and had no idea what to do to
save his family at night Stephanie walks
downstairs and hears her parents
discussing ways to keep her under
control Eric seems positive believing
that Stephanie can control her emotions
while Jane thinks otherwise she suggests
that they perform a brain procedure but
Erica poses it stating that it has high
risks he also continuously mentions that
he doesn't want to lose his daughter
Stephanie who's hearing all of this
doesn't say a word and simply returns to
her room to sleep in her dream she hears
a strange sound coming from the other
side of the entrance door slowly she
walks towards it and notices that it is
already open suddenly when she
approaches the door it closes making her
terrified despite this she slowly opens
it again and finds her father's ghost on
the other side with this she starts
screaming and eventually wakes up from
her nightmare however Stephanie is still
not convinced that it was only Her
Imagination hence she goes downstairs
and stands in front of the same door but
just then her parents arrive and comfort
her Stephanie tells Eric that she saw
the monster killing him in her dream and
as soon as she says this the entrance
door opens all of a sudden and an unseen
paranormal Force drags Eric out seeing
this Jane carries Stephanie and takes
her to a hiding place inside a closet
Stephanie asks her mother to remain calm
and silent so that the monster won't
hear them and return after a while
everything goes silent and Jane steps
out of the closet to check around when
she notices nothing she confirms to the
little girl that everything is under
control but unfortunately when she asks
Stephanie to accompany her she is pulled
by the same unseen Force frightened
Stephanie runs to a room grabs Francis
and jumps from the window she injures
herself in the process but gets right
back up and tries to climb a ladder and
back to the house Eric and Jane try to
stop her but to no avail as the Unseen
Force which seems to be originating from
the little girl herself keeps dragging
them back fortunately Jane uses the last
of her strength and pulls Stephanie down
from the ladder but their troubles are
far from over as the parents lie on the
ground a strange creature with tentacles
tries to attack them from all sides Jane
orders her daughter to stop but the
little girl is so afraid that she
doesn't comply but before any damage is
caused Jane whips out a chloroformed
handkerchief and puts it against Steph's
face hence putting her to sleep now with
the creature silenced she tells
Stephanie you are the monster the next
day Stephanie wakes up and apologizes to
her parents for running out of the house
without their permission Eric Comforts
her and reveals that she is a monster
Insider that is controlling her
activities and her mind comforting
indeed with the help of some pendulum
balls he then tries to hypnotize
Stephanie and asks her about what she
did to Paul the little girl closes her
eyes and reveals that while she and Paul
were carving pumpkins for Halloween he
started teasing her this is why she
attacked him with all her arms I.E
tentacles saying this much she again
starts becoming violent but Jane calms
her down with a vaccine following this
the parents take Stephanie to an
operation room and Jane proceeds to cut
her head open Eric tries to stop his
wife from doing so but she mentions that
it is the only way to keep her alive and
safe it turns out that she wants to
remove the monster by conducting a brain
surgery unfortunately just before the
procedure can begin the possessed little
girl regains her Consciousness and
destroys the whole Lab with her powers
in the next scene Eric is watching the
news which mentions that the medical
procedure conducted worldwide to treat
children like Stephanie has gone wrong
and the large number of doctors and
other medical personnel have been killed
in the process in the news it is also
mentioned that the medical procedure was
the last hope to find a cure now that it
has failed the only remaining option is
to euthanize the children suffering from
this rare condition in the morning
Stephanie acts as if nothing has
happened on the other hand the parents
plot to kill their daughter by poisoning
her hot chocolate Eric then asks
Stephanie to accompany him for a walk in
the woods while the father-daughter Duo
bonds outside Stephanie apologizes to
her father for hurting him Eric is moved
by the comments but after a short pause
he asks his daughter to drink the hot
chocolate but right before she can drink
it her telekinesis Powers throw the
sipper away and her face starts to turn
blue she tries to control herself but
fails compelling Eric to reach out for
his gun and shoot her multiple times
after the incident a distraught Eric
returns home believing that Stephanie
has died he cries profusely and
expresses his guilt for what he has done
however the next day when he proceeds to
bury Stephanie's body he finds her
standing at the back door of the fence a
dumb founded Eric tries to react but
Stephanie gives him no chance and throws
him in the air with her telekinesis
power she then heads towards the
bathroom to find Jane and brings her
downstairs mercilessly striking her on
the walls following this she stabs Eric
with a knife and breaks Jane's bones
killing them instantly and telling them
that they should have never returned in
the last scene she destroys the whole
house with her telekinesis Powers drags
her parents bodies outdoors and abandons
them at Paul's grave she also destroys
the other properties in the neighborhood
after dropping and stepping on her toy
turtle allegedly to demonstrate that she
has been taken over by the force it
appears as though her Shadow has now
extended tentacles like a giant octopus
the movie ends as we are given an aerial
shot of the entire Earth which has been
completely ravaged by deadly fires this
indicates that several other telekinetic
children are alive and kicking subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching